after all this time spider-man never met
hawkeye or loki what kind of spider is
he anyway a recluse want more surprising
mcu heroes that never entered spidey's
web keep watching
while it's true that peter parker and
natasha romanov fought his allies under
team tony stark in captain america civil
war the two arachnid-themed avengers
didn't really get to know each other at
the airport battle as audiences saw in
peter's videos of his trip to germany in
spider-man homecoming the young hero
didn't take part in iron man's strategic
meetings with his fellow sokovia accords
enforcers and when spider-man left into
battle most of his energy and attention
went to fighting the falcon the winter
soldier captain america and ant-man by
the time the skirmish ended natasha had
already run away after turning traitor
while spider-man was taken out of
commission due to injuries sustained
from the giant-sized ant-man's
accidental backhand spider-man and the
black widow would later find themselves
fighting against a common enemy once
more albeit on different battlegrounds
in avengers infinity war but it doesn't
seem like they had a chance to cross
paths spidey was taking the fight
directly to thanos on titan while black
widow fought in the battle of wakanda to
stop thanos forces from taking the last
infinity stone sadly peter was among
those who vanished in the blip and while
he did manage to return to the land of
the living natasha had to sacrifice her
life to make that possible
save for his impromptu trip to space in
avengers infinity war the mcu spider-man
is a self-described friendly
neighborhood hero who's more comfortable
going on grounded street level
adventures unsurprisingly many of the
heroes he hasn't met in this universe
are of the cosmic variety and he can't
get more otherworldly than the god of
thunder himself thor the first time
spider-man and thor had an opportunity
to meet each other was during the final
battle in avengers end game however they
didn't even get the chance to banter
though the web slinger did get to fly
through the sky via mjolnir thanks to a
last minute save from the unexpectedly
worthy steve rogers after tony stark's
funeral the asgardian decided to join
the guardians of the galaxy as part of a
period of self-reflection while the
spider-powered teenager continued to
serve as one of new york's few remaining
active superheroes
in the comics peter parker and bruce
banner are among the brightest
scientific minds in their universe as
for their alter egos while the hulk is
one of earth's mightiest warriors
spider-man's no slouch in the strength
department either thus it would have
been simultaneously amazing and
incredible to see peter parker talk
science with bruce banner and to watch
spider-man and the hulk have a marvelous
team-up while spider-man was busy
helping tony stark bring in steve rogers
in captain america civil war the green
behemoth was off world in avengers
infinity war spider-man lent a
much-needed helping hand to iron man in
fighting off call obsidian largely
because the hulk didn't want to come out
of bruce following his defeat at the
hands of thanos it doesn't seem like
spidey and bruce had much of a chance to
trade contact info during the battle
while webhead and jay jaws both pitched
in during the final battle in avengers
end game the two could have been science
bros didn't really have the chance to
partner up
all things considered the guardians of
the galaxy would probably seem like an
interesting crew for peter parker a
weirdly charismatic team of oddballs and
outlaws with a strange sense of humor
while he did get to converse with half
the team in avengers infinity war the
fact that peter hadn't had any
meaningful interactions with rocket
groot or gamora should be rectified in a
future mcu production as for the other
half of the team spider-man fought
alongside star-lord drax mantis and
nebula and titan in a failed attempt to
take the infinity gauntlet from thanos
before he could complete the infinity
stones this ended in spidey and some of
the surviving guardians getting dusted
and staying dead for five years upon
their return in avengers endgame
spider-man found himself allied in
battle with the guardians once again as
well as a time-displaced version of
gamora however despite being on the same
battlefield spider-man didn't really get
the opportunity to meet the rest of the
crew
when ant-man sided with captain
america's team in captain america civil
war he didn't have the wasp on his side
for a brief period of time though the
wasp almost made it to team cap's roster
before the russo brothers decided that
the story of her introduction would be
better served in a movie that didn't
already have too many characters and
story storylines on its plate while the
decision to have scott lang join team
cap without hope van dyne ultimately
allowed her to have a proper official
costume debut in ant-man and the wasp it
was still a missed opportunity for the
stinging super heroine to butt heads
against spider-man spider-man and the
wasp would later get a shot at fighting
on the same side in avengers end game
following their revival after getting
dusted by thanos however they still
didn't get the chance to interact with
each other during the extremely crowded
final fight and despite the fact that
they both showed up at tony stark's
funeral audiences didn't get to see them
meet each other or swap stories
despite her significant role in thor's
early mcu mythology lady siff hasn't
been seen that often in subsequent
movies in fact she didn't even show up
in thor ragnarok and was confirmed to
have died during the blip in avengers
infinity war it's safe to assume that
like the rest of the heroes brought back
in avengers endgame the fierce asgardian
warrior was alive during the final
battle against thanos but audiences
didn't get to see her if so incidentally
this also meant that spider-man likely
never got to meet her or witness her
abilities on the battlefield
realistically there probably isn't much
that spider-man and lady sif would have
to talk about nor would they really have
any solid reason to interact
nevertheless it's always a treat to see
how a conversation between an earthling
and an asgardian goes especially if said
conversation involved the jocular
spider-man and the somewhat serious lady
sif either way hopefully they get along
better than sif and loki did
i hope you know you deserve to be alone
and you always will be
[Music]
speaking of the god of mischief if peter
parker ever gets to meet loki their
encounter would doubtlessly be full of
hilarity spider-man's humorous jabs and
naive observations would probably amuse
or irk the trickster god while loki's
penchant for deception and dishonesty
would likely befuddle the webslinger
that's why it's a shame these two
characters never met in an mcu
production despite the fact that loki
has been on earth multiple times none of
his mid-guardian adventures have caused
his path to cross with spider-man while
spidey and the rest of the avengers were
busy trying to fend off thanos in
avengers end game a version of loki that
branched out from the timeline of 2012's
the avengers ended up having his own
adventures on his eponymous disney plush
show
if one were to be technical about it
peter parker did have at least one
significant albeit brief moment of
collaboration with king t'challa at a
critical point in avengers end game the
teen superhero snags the infinity
gauntlet from black panther with a web
line in an attempt to take it as far
away from thanos as possible despite
this however the black panther still
belongs on this list simply because he
and spider-man have not really had any
meaningful and direct interactions
despite being on the same battlefield
not once but twice the first opportunity
that spider-man and the black panther
could have had for formal introductions
took place in captain america civil war
during the lengthy airport battle scene
however both superheroes had their hands
full trying to subdue their respective
opponents and didn't really get the
opportunity for chit chat considering
that chadwick boseman sadly passed away
in 2020 it seems that their brief
interaction in end game will be the
extent of their relationship for the
foreseeable future
clint barton is one of the mcu's
founding avengers and also happens to be
one of the most oft underestimated
heroes in the cinematic universe due to
his lack of fancy abilities nevertheless
he has proven countless times that he
can hold his own in the company of
earth's mightiest heroes and has played
a crucial role in virtually every major
battle since the avengers were founded
he even helped the heroes win the day
against thanos forces in avengers
endgame unfortunately his part in that
grand skirmish did not involve meeting
spider-man at all among all the mcu's
super powered heroes peter parker is
perhaps the most human without a doubt
he would find some form of kinship in
clint who could probably teach him a
thing or two about acting more mature
and getting over his insecurities in
front of the costume superhero crowd if
hawkeye's uneasy partnership with kate
bishop in the disney plus hawkeye series
is any indication the avenging archer
would actually make a better teacher for
a young hero like spider-man than he'd
be willing to admit
spider-man and the vision fought side by
side in captain america civil war under
the leadership of iron man however much
like the other heroes that joined team
tony spider-man didn't get the chance to
interact with the infinity stone-powered
synthezoid on the silver screen this
lack of interaction between spider-man
and the vision in mcu movies is a missed
opportunity for the young scientists to
be able to understand cutting-edge
technology and artificial intelligence
from a radically different point of view
in a world full of gamma-powered monster
men and hammer-wielding gods an
artificial being like the vision still
pushes the boundaries of modern
technology and there's little doubt that
the science-inclined spider-man would be
thrilled at the prospect of talking to a
life-like machine on the flip side
spending more time with spider-man could
help the vision to better understand
what it means to be a human being
hopefully a future marvel movie could
provide an opportunity for peter to flex
his scientific prowess while helping the
vision in his mission to come to terms
with his own humanity
for the first decade of the mcu's run
chongqi has been completely absent from
silver screen depictions of its world
shaking events and because the super
heroic martial artist only made his
debut in 2021 chongqi it's not
surprising that he hasn't had the chance
to meet many of the mcu's heroes
including spider-man that said it's
worth noting that chongqi takes place
after the blip was undone and likely
before the events of spider-man far from
home in other words when chongqi first
shows up on everyone's radar peter
parker isn't on the run yet as a result
of mysterio blowing his secret identity
wide open realistically there's plenty
of time for spider-man and chongqi to
meet maybe chongqi could teach peter
parker a thing or two when it comes to
martial arts
you have the wrong guy does he look like
he can fight come on bro
despite being on earth for an extremely
long time the eternals have been
conspicuously absent from virtually all
of the major battles that kept it safe
from alien invaders and would-be
conquerors this explains why the mcu
heroes including spider-man have never
crossed paths with them in previous
films however with the departure of many
mcu mainstays following the events of
venture's endgame there's plenty of room
in the sandbox for the eternals to play
and just as many opportunities for them
to get tangled up in spider-man's web in
an interview with screen rant the cast
members were asked which mcu heroes
they'd be most excited to work with
interestingly two of them name-dropped
spider-man according to don lee he'd
love to test his strength against the
hulk or team up with spider-man if he
reprises his role as gilgamesh meanwhile
for liam mchugh who plays sprite the
answer is a no-brainer of course
spider-man tom holland duh i would
absolutely love to be in a movie with
him hey get in line
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]